hi i'm ben platt and i play evan hansen
i'm caitlin deiver and i play zoe murphy
i'm amandla sundberg and i play alana
beck i'm nick o'donnie and i play jared
kawani i'm colton ryan and i play connor
murphy and we are the cast of dear evan
hansen we're here with buzzfeed to play
the game
who's who
you want to kick us off yeah sure
[Music]
who is most likely to start laughing and
break character during a
take oh
it's really inconsistent here i thought
my hand went the wrong way everyone's
crazy themselves who was okay i pointed
at myself looking at you i pointed at
caitlyn i'm pointing at colton okay are
you joking
there's no definitive winner here
there's no definitive way it looks like
we all break you can share a day no but
i just
i just know i've ruined a lot of takes
with laughter that's made people wait
around
every time
i really walked down the hallway when i
screamed at him you know i screamed at
him and i walked past and i was like
every time i always every time like it
felt very good didn't see it thank you
character that was like you were really
good
it was just like okay i earned my job so
everyone yeah everybody everybody's in
the world yeah everyone's really really
bad at it
exactly none of us we're all
unprofessional okay who's the best at
doing impressions of other cast members
yet to see i know i was like impressions
of me okay
caitlyn do an impression of ben
oh wait no
i can't do an impression of this not to
like put you on the spot or anything she
went oh wait is there something over
there oh my god
what is that
who is most likely to randomly burst
into song on set we didn't even have to
wait no no waiting no do you have a
defense i have no defense i never stop
singing and whistling and humming at any
time that's true i would i was worried i
would start my mornings by listening to
ben sing upstairs because we live
together so
he's always singing doing them warm ups
a warm-up playlist in the shower it's
quite cool it's annoying because i've
never heard you do it bad like you know
like yeah it's so annoying yeah like in
the shower like you croak and things and
like never heard that
i make healthy sounds so
[Laughter]
who's most likely to laugh during a
really awkward situation
that's true actually that is definitely
true
i don't know yeah it's a tie between the
two of you i think
i think i did it all day today
are you saying this is awkward no
i have no coping mechanisms other than
humor
and that's good i agree is it control
for life i think it's good who is most
likely to win a game of musical theater
trivia
but like yes absolutely love it but i
feel like colton too a little bit
closer if we were like an avengers team
up
who's most likely to give the best
relationship advice
me not me nick really yeah because you
have given me
good relationship advice
and you're very calm
okay
it's me rewrote this yeah mm-hmm wow i
only said colton because you've been in
such an impressive long-term long term
yeah
oh yeah i love the atrium yeah who is
most likely to accidentally like an old
picture on their crush's instagram oh
boy
me
i'm pointing at you i'm pointing at
myself
you're pointing at me too no it was
scaling
[Laughter]
who's most likely to get caught taking a
selfie
i feel like all of us
yeah your arm is
that's true the only documentation we
have i feel like
oh yes
very true thank you it's like a brow and
an eye and frame from you and then the
background
the pictures aren't great but you know
we have the mems
who's most likely to spontaneously get a
tattoo after a night out
you will be found
[Music]
oh a little apple could be kind of cute
instead of the oh are we getting apples
you guys just
oh let's all get a tattoo who is most
likely to send a funny meme or video to
a group chat with the cast these two
these two yeah yeah yeah
you're always oh yeah you have good
stuff good good content
i am on the talk
yeah yeah good content all right
buzzfeed thank you so much just make
sure that you go ahead and you check out
dear evan hansen in theaters
now no
no right now
you